it's now 47 democrats who are very
concerned about the administration's
plans to shell title 42 next month i
remember when it used to be just one
my next guest henry cuellar the texas
congressman kind enough to join us
right now congressman very good to see
you there are 46 others now who share
your concern
but way beyond title 42 but it looks
like title 42 is still going to go away
the administration talks about
a backup plan a new plan do you know
anything about that plan
you know i've seen parts of it and part
of it means that they want to bring
officers from the northern part over to
the southern area and you know neil that
that's going to be just something that's
going to be temporary
and and the metrics that i think they're
looking at is how do we move the
migrants faster from the border to the
interior and i i don't think that's a
plan without due respect and this is why
there's other democrats senators and
congressmen that have a problem
because what we're seeing is it's
literally a open border it's an open
border and the more
people come in across and the title 42
goes away the numbers are going to
definitely increase and we're going to
see uh you know a situation where uh
border patrol is going to continue to be
overwhelmed you know congressman i
remember you and you were very honest
about it you you know you blasted
republicans and democrats for not doing
more to come up with comprehensive
reform be that as it may early on with
the obama administration you were also
trying to say what we've got is a
serious problem here and it's getting
much much worse
how has the administration responded to
you personally congressman and your
constant entreaties and warnings about
this
well you know i certainly have talked to
folks at the white house and at the
homeland security and i think the career
people that is the men and women in
green and blue
understand what the problem is they
understand what the problem is but
unfortunately
some folks only look at the the the
stakeholders of the activists the
immigration activists but i don't think
they're paying attention to the men and
women in green and blue and they're
certainly not listening to the border
communities the sheriff's uh the judges
the mayors and people uh down at the
border or the land owners itself so you
gotta listen to the communities at the
border and you certainly have to listen
to our men and women from homeland you
know we're getting different vibes from
the white house though congressman i
know the homeland security secretary
alejandro mariocras had acknowledged
that the the planned end of title 42 uh
could pose significant challenges for
the u.s government but it does not
appear uh that at least at this point i
could be missing something
is is hearing that or responding to that
well you know i think anybody that's
familiar uh with homeland understands
that there is a problem and this problem
is going to be magnified after may 23rd
the criminal organizations know exactly
what our policies are what our policies
are not and they have been promoting and
marketing that uh after the may 23rd uh
the borders are going to be wide open
and the more people they bring in as you
know you know let's say the average is
eight thousand dollars per individual
the more money they make so they they're
gonna market this they're gonna go ahead
and promote this uh and use this policy
and a lack of a plan uh at the border to
send more people over here i mean neil
look in in six months we had
over one million encounters and and that
doesn't even include the getaways uh
this last month we had 221 000
individuals so the numbers are going to
continue uh getting larger and larger
and it's yeah it's unfortunate and i'm
glad that i there are other democrats uh
both in the senate and the congress that
are seeing what i've been seeing for a
while
do um some in the party tell you to shut
up do they prefer that you not keep
mentioning this
no actually you know some of the uh my
colleagues uh understand what i'm doing
uh now some of your colleagues are
nervous and looking at the midterms you
were doing this long before the midterms
so i'm wondering do they
and did you go through a period there
where hey uh just just pipe down
no i i never had anybody tell me that uh
i i assume some of them were probably
thinking that but i can tell you my
republican colleagues have been telling
me you know in jazz but they mean this
they're saying boy you sure are you know
the administration is handing over
a perfect narrative for republicans to
go after democrats in november uh and
they just don't understand why that's
being handed over to the republicans
this narrative of open borders uh down
at the uh in our southern area
congressman i still have you there was a
great hullabaloo not too many months
back when uh fbi agents raided your home
they were taking boxes out you have
since said i think sir that there was
some sort of a probe going on but that
uh you are not a target in that could
you update me
well that's uh what my attorney uh told
me uh from his conversations with the
department and again listen i got three
brothers there are peace officers i have
a great respect to law enforcement i'll
continue to go ahead and cooperate but i
think at the end of the day they will
show that there was no wrong doing how
did you feel about that i mean that out
of the blue no warning to you and
they're they're they're
you know ramshacking your place
well uh again you know it's uh it
certainly is one of those situations
that i uh don't worship on anybody uh
but again uh you know working with my
attorney you heard what my attorneys say
right uh said and again we will continue
uh working with our uh law enforcement
and i think at the end of the day it
will show that there was no wrongdoing
all right do you do you know what they
were looking for or what they thought
they were looking for
well i again i'll leave i'll leave it to
my attorneys that go ahead and go into
details but uh but you know enough to
say that you are not a target of
something the fbi might be looking for
that that you're pretty sure
that is what my attorney has told me yes
sir okay congressman thank you very very
much henry cuellar the texas congressman
was warning about what was going on the
border for anyone and certainly before
these now 46 other uh democratic
politicians were jumping on the
title 42 bandwagon i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now